[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
all
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm Maxim vag and you're watching the S
field Cup live in St
Louis hello and welcome back to our
coverage of the sing field cup we've got
a solution for you on the puzzle that
you were solving over the break between
sakala and aonan and Grandmaster Ashley
has that for us well we sort of have a
double question for you we asked what's
the winning move well you had to be a
detective and figure out who it was that
was on turn well clearly I mean sakov is
not playing in the tournament so you
would have guessed that it is Black's
turn to move since aonian number two in
the world is playing here now this
position is complicated you've got to be
number two in the world or thereabouts
to solve this puzzle the move he played
in this position where black is clearly
ahead in development White's pieces on
the king side are not out at all white
has only three pieces in play while
black has four in play and is ready to
Castle this poor King looks terrible and
aonian figured out how to take advantage
of it by playing the move Rook to C8 a
spectacular move in this position just
put that up and daring white to capture
on A5 because after Rook takes on C5
it's not possible for this queen to
guard this Rook that's under attack from
the black queen and simultaneously deal
with the move Queen to C3 check that's
just devastating a big body blow in the
position so instead of being able to
take the bishop soov had to gravel with
the move Rook A2 and then suddenly Rook
takes on C5 exploiting the pin along
this long diagonal to the king you
cannot touch the Rook of course because
the king would be in check so just a
straight Pawn loss and now Queen A1
begging for a trade hoping Beyond hope
for a queen trade but met by this
spectacular move Queen to
C6 donating a rook to the cause but only
now caring about Checkmate to the white
king white threw in the move Queen E5
check but then King to d8 sidest
Stepping that and now white decided to
rip off The Rook might as well but after
King D7 he had no more checks in the
position and looking at the position he
realized that he couldn't deal properly
with the move Rook to C1 Checkmate if he
had brought his Rook back then of course
Rook to C1 would follow immediately and
it's still Checkmate after the capture
on C1 Queen follows behind and instead
if in this position he had played Rook
to D2 to try to help out well then Rook
to C1 check Rook to D1 and now Queen to
C2 attacking that Rook twice and after
Queen D4 trying to to help out but we
get back to the Thematic idea of Rook
takes Queen takes and queen C3 check
forcing Queen to D2 and queen takes D2
mate for the first puzzle of the day boy
our Puzzle Master has thrown us a tough
one we should at least warm up with like
a made in two that one was rough maybe
you saw it if not don't worry it's a
2800 that solves those kind of puzzles
guys that's right I like the queen tank
G5 Rook F7 Rook H7 made yesterday by mag
that was a good warm up I I remember
that game between Ivon sakov and leavon
aronian when it was played it was really
talked about in the world of Chess you
don't see a top grandm like Ivon soof
getting taken out so decisively with the
white pieces speaking of decisively
we've got another note on those puzzles
actually the music from them is actually
um part of the another singfield love
which is music certainly so um Genie
singfield um who also is a founder of
the chess club is also really big into
promoting music and one of that was a
local composition exactly a winner of
the singfield prize um Katie Andre and
that's the kta for the horn and the 2007
singfield Prize winner wonderful very
nice piece and we're hearing that right
now can't hear it oh I can it's lovely
all right um big developments in our key
match up between world champion Magnus
Carlson and Fabiana Carana what we have
seen a very surprising move for me was
this move H2 H3 by Magnus a deep
strategic move by mag H2 perhaps well
and also in this particular case
threatening that Knight takes E5 because
there's no longer that Bishop G4 trap so
essentially this move H2 H3 three says
um you better take my Bishop which he
did but capturing the
bishop the obvious result is these
double pawns on G3 and G2 a big
strategic uh concession by white but
opening up The Rook on F1 but opening up
The Rook on F1 and your point from
earlier about castling being potentially
problematic because of KN H4 mhm with
the Strategic threat of Knight F5 and
the Tactical threat of Knight G six uh
holds especially true here because you
can't even move that Rook on f8 away
because of the F7 pressure placed by The
Rook on F1 and the bishop so exactly I
don't even I don't see how you would
react to that that seems bad exactly so
Fabiana did not castle and instead he
sought to uh neutralize this bishop on
B3 with the move Knight C5 threatening
to grab yet again a second bishop and
only Magus already had A3 and he would
certainly whip out too oh my goodness I
think the position just exploded if I've
got this right he sacrificed a piece
with Bishop takes F7 check takes F7 and
the game has W you were right we see
that on the
webcam quite confidently and rather
quickly right he just snapped that pawn
on F7 Bishop takes F7 check and the
tournament leader Fabiana Carana
returned to the board and clasped his
head oh my goodness did I overlook
something he's thinking so let us go
through these ramifications how many
pawns is he going to get here it looks
like two well first of all if we capture
with the bishop pardon me capture the
bishop with the queen we are looking at
this Knight takes E5 with the double
attack and keep in mind that Queen H5
check is going to be a a destruction
I'm thinking that black has got to
capture with the King pause for just a
moment we going we we're going to make a
a discover check but should we open up
this bishop or not just play Knight H4
check exactly so Knight H4 a double uh a
discovered check against the king the
king would likely drop back to
G8 fortunately for white for black
there's no Queen B3 check so we're going
to look at this move Knight to G B6 with
the intention of either capturing that
Rook or playing Rook f8 check will drop
back with the queen let's just hoping to
sacrifice and get after RF F you're
getting enough wood there huh right but
we we pause it here because we there's
no uh necessity for playing Rook f8
check right away I'm thinking about the
move Queen
H5 to so it's a positional peace
sacrifice all we we've got is one Pawn
at the moment no Queen H5 just doesn't
feel right just a second here no because
you see the more pieces coming to the
defense right yeah for instance right so
we've got to go for it right away let's
say check takes takes King takes what
else so technically Black's up in wait
Black's got threeie three pieces and a
rook for a queen
okay for a Queen Bishop Knight and Rook
bishop and Knight and Rook for Queen
right yes okay now two Bishops two
Bishops and a rook right right so we can
we can flick in the move B2
B4 um I'm not 100% sure that that would
be so effective
start let's start with the more obvious
Queen
H5 uh answered by Bishop E6 developing
jump over here with the Rook I don't see
this as actually leading into any
decisive Advantage for white but wait a
minute this move Queen G6 does threaten
B2 B4 winning a piece since his Bishop
on E6 requires pressure is on Fabiano
Parana now exactly and mag been eight
minutes on this move okay very key key
moment so let's continue this line H5 it
still seems wild Your
Castle I mean I told you wait didn't I
say never Castle yeah
I uh never Castle uh is what I heard
maice what's your take on this one this
has gotten wild instantly with this
extraordinary move Bishop F7
check well yes what an amazing move a
spectacular shot just out the blue
blowing up the position and you can see
that Karana did not even suspect that it
was there but who would have this move
does not show up on the computer's first
choice of moves whatsoever Bishop takes
on F7 boom now we are wide awake if we
were just leading back before this is an
amazing move first of all Queen takes F7
fails straightforward fashion as well
Knight takes on E5 and the point here is
that the queen is under attack this
queen is looking to come to H5 that
would be unstoppable and if you play
this variation Queen takes takes F1 and
after Knight takes F1 trying to get
three pieces in this line then of course
Queen H5 check comes in nice and Rosy
and white is Happy the computer is
saying after Bishop takes F7 King takes
bravely going into the discovered check
now Knight takes on E5 it deems best
King to G8 allowing Knight to G6 and now
the move Queen G5 is the defensive move
you won't believe the long en forcing
line here to a Advantage by the way for
white for black excuse me after Rook
check King up attacking the Knight now
Knight takes rook and in this position
Queen E3 check King
over and this amazing move Bishop to G4
now his turn to have a discovered attack
on white attacking that Rook on f8 best
move according to computer Queen takes
and Rook takes and now this Knight is
trapped must come back out and now Rook
to F6 and this Knight is hanging this
Knight is hanging white must play Knight
F1 at least best move for now and then
Queen takes on
e4 in this position and after Queen
takes a knight takes suddenly we have a
position where White's just simply well
white at the moment is up a pawn but the
Knight is under attack and when it comes
out then Knight takes here Knight takes
and Rook takes let's just consider this
the forcing line air quotes
but white is no longer up black has a
fantastic Bishop the position is even
but that's the one difference is that
dark Square Bishop obviously there are
multiple lines for us to analyze here to
try to clarify all this but this is
right now the pressing main line by the
engine will Carana notice all these
moves and steer his way through the
ridiculous complications of this line
obviously multiple moves he's now been
shocked by a bishop sacri ice on F7
remember Bishop C4 and move two was
aiming at F7 but that was for the old
days nobody gets to take on F7 these
days do they here we
are wow we're getting some great
responses um from our Twitter listeners
our Twitter account just exploded that's
right um we've got carace who says that
Carlson's Bishop takes up seven check is
so baller we've got uh Chris bird the
international Arbiter who points out
that MBL is checking out the Carlson
carolana game and giving some fun looks
even though it's his move in his game so
Bishop takes up seven so shocking that
the other players stopped thinking on
their games they ran over to look at uh
what's going on in this board wow Muno
is the talented young player who is uh
the co-champion of the national girls
Invitational and also the first US
junior girls clo occurred this year and
she won that title on tiebreak wonderful
she said that she guesses Fabiana will
not be castling today indeed those are
the rules of chat right well Bish Bishop
F F7 I would uh if in Fabiana shoes I'd
step back and just try to be as calm as
I could after uh being shocked by this
mov s and and speaking of which uh
another listener chess Network says he'd
like to know the exact moment of at at
Bishop F7 what Fabiano's heart rate
was yeah just we know chess is a
dangerous game I mean we've had a lot of
people pass away on the chess board and
that is a move that would make uh Bishop
takes F7 King takes F7 has been played
King takes I mean Force now um in the
line that Maurice was talking about and
the computer's engine computer's engine
was taking this Pawn on E5 and I shied
away from that just because I was
looking at that Bishop that dark Square
Bishop suddenly being activated along
the diagonal My First Choice was for
Knight H4 check I don't know if the
computer uh considered this line and how
it evaluated the queen versus uh two
minor pieces in Rook variation I suspect
uh the the machine is going to say oh
just grab the material and hang on hey
question um Bishop takes F7 check do you
think there's a what do you think the
chances are that Fabiano didn't even
consider
it I think he actually saw it but he
just kind of diss dissed it it's a
question of how much he looked at but I
think it's just kind of instinctive if
you're not castled and you're a strong
chess player and he's not just strong
he's decent in his words decent number
two in the world it's just impossible
it's almost like an instinct right like
brushing your teeth like obviously you
Bishop takes s it's a move it's legal
right but the nothing that you really
pay attention to how much did he analyze
it as a question very very little and
Hikaru Nakamura also finding this game
extremely fascinating stepping away from
his game with topalo players wishing
they could play tag team right they are
going to get a chance to do a little tag
team later in the event we've got The
Ultimate Showdown which is going to be a
great exhibition matches exactly yeah
that comes at the end of the tournament
Maurice back to you
just a quick point Y just to answer the
question that you you posed Knight H4
was considered by the engine but it
thinks that this line does not work out
well for white and it seems as though
Carlson has agreed because he's taken on
E5 after Knight H4 King G8 Knight to G6
the simple Queen E8 and after The Rook
goes down with check take the Rook
Knight takes and King takes and it
thinks that the attack beginning with
Queen H5 really is not going to hold up
and it can defend well we know know how
confident again in quotes computers are
in their ability to defend if they don't
see the mate or they don't see the way
you get your material back they're just
going to hold it and hang on and figure
out some way to maneuver out of the
danger so that's what the choice was for
for Carlson he decided instead to take
on E5 and it looks as though karwana has
calmed down a bit he went beat red guys
when he came back to the board you could
see it he was intense looking at that
sacrifice but I think he's starting to
realize that it's maybe a b bit of a
bluff he's not going to go down in
flames and if he plays the right moves
according to the engi black is the one
who's going to have the advantage
guys thank you for thank you Maurice for
that uh and indeed so far uh Magnus has
played the computer's main variation now
from fabiana's point of view the move
Queen G5 here is intuitively kind of
obvious because obviously the queen is
under attack so you've got to move the
queen and you start thinking well gee
with this bishop aiming towards White's
King this move Queen
G5 Rook f8 check the these moves are
very easy for Fabiana to calculate now
here is where he really could run into a
little bit of a problem because he might
start thinking hey I've got great
opportunity myself to go and seize the
initiative with the move Bishop takes H3
for example bringing uh the Rooks into
play Rook takes and now Queen takes uh
G3 with threats of Checkmate or what
that that nasty little check that uh
that um Maurice had been pointing out
earlier moves like Queen E3 check if you
can get the guy to move his King
cooperate and move his King into the
corner well then you're looking at Queen
takes G3 and check this out Jen mates
over here on H2 mates over here on G2 so
it's and then play something passive
here like uh Queen G1 Queen G1 then you
might drop back with the bishop right
threatening Queen H4 again threatening
Queen H4 again check pardon me uh the
bishop Bishop meant to be dropped back
to G4 so this is a a position where
Karana would look at the move Queen G5
Knight you can play like Knight F1 and
Knight H2 to there how much quite how
much material is white up anyway a lot
so a lot right so after that Bishop H3
line after Queen G1 and Knight F1 were
kind of hanging on right right I'm
thinking so I think that honestly though
I believe that the the big difference
between the computer variation that we
saw in the game with Magnus where Queen
D3 MH I think that Magnus had like three
minutes at that time whereas Fabiano's
got a lot of time here yes so I actually
think there's good chances he's going to
you know figure out how defend here
because uh the line is so forcing and
he's got a lot of time well and there's
a flow uh the grand Masters can
calculate very well uh when you have
this flowing forcing line so again from
the start it looks to me like Queen G3
minutes actually yes yeah would be an
optimal looking move Fabiano would
calculate Queen G5 check King takes the
rook and now you always look at checks
those are the checks are the most for
forcing moves so you look at the most
forcing moves first check to the king
now I think Maurice's Main Line it
actually continued King H1 now here's
where you have a okay so why can we need
three check first what's the difference
because you want the king over here on
the H file in that other variation with
the bishop takes
H3 Rook takes H I'm saying is our
difference between playing this bishop
G4 move
first uh sorry you're playing you're
Queen E3 check followed by Bishop G4
right yes and so I'm asking if Bishop G4
immediately Bishop G4
immediately I think you're I guess you
can play just uh you're no Knight F3 is
not an option I think you're giving
white at is no Knight F7 isn't an option
you're giving white perhaps an
opportunity uh opportunity to capture
the rook and what's the body count after
a variation like this
I'm not sure well you got two Rooks for
the queen but my attack seems to persist
after Queen E3 check and Knight D3
that's got to be very good for black
agreed agreed agreed so so I'm just
trying to see if there's actually a
difference there m um so the idea is
that after to review the idea after
Queen takes
G4 well again let's look at the most
forcing I mean you got to look at the
checks okay right you got to look at the
checks first so I'm thinking check King
H1 right so far so good and let's toss
in just a moment let's toss in Queen
takes before looking at the bishop G4
move do you think like because Fabiano
is going to be looking at Bishop H3 and
queen G3 is more forcing moves first
exactly I'm thinking yeah I'm thinking
that Fabiano is thinking okay let's
pursue the most aggressive line it may
be wrong but let's yeah for sure the
noral way to calculate right Bishop
takes G3 you were going to do queen G3
okay well let's let's try Bishop takes
H3 CU we're capturing and we're
threatening to capture on G2 and then
we're threatening to capture on G3
because the problem with Queen G3
immediately is what you worried about
like just Knight F1 defending with the
tempo yes yeah okay so that makes sense
so Bishop takes H3 uh preparing to play
Rook takes f8 let's just imagine Rook
takes A8 for the moment yes fair enough
um Queen takes G3 now or Bishop takes G2
check Bishop takes G2 check let's give
this a look see spin King takes a spin
it's out for a spin okay so King F1
avoiding getting only move and now uh i'
I've Got a Feeling I've got at least a
Perpetual check here if not more after
check that Knight on C5 guards the D3
Square which is pretty important isn't
it precisely it's simply it's Checkmate
well King
E2 Checkmate oh no no you have King King
E1 you were thinking after King F2 yeah
King E1 I was thinking Checkmate here so
King F oops well I was thinking you
could also
play King F2 I've got at least a perpet
play Queen G2 check instead earlier uh
let's say here yes yeah I was saying
Queen G2 check here so now King E3 fails
to Bishop G3 check so you must go up to
E3 right King E1 fails to Bishop G3 mate
so King e so Fabio I think he has at
least a Perpetual check in these
sacrificial lines okay that's why the
computer liked the bishop G4 variation
because it thinks that black is better
and shouldn't go for the Perpetual check
if I understand so that is very
interesting so Fabiano with a lot to
think about
here very fascinating tactical
variations and worth asking yourself
these questions as you analyze with your
computer asking yourself the obvious
questions right what about taking G3 and
threading made on one and as you answer
those questions you can understand the
the depth of the position better right
well exactly but something else happens
what happens as the grand Masters are
analyzing first of all if Fabiano sees a
variation where he has a Perpetual check
it's like an enormous sense of relief
it's like okay great I've got the draw
in hand and then when you realize that
you have the draw in hand and you
recover from the shock of Bishop F7
check then you start thinking
ambitiously and saying okay now that I
know I've got the draw in hand do I have
a
win so let's so this bishop F7 check as
Maurice described it it's explosive move
but it might just BL it might just be
Bluff we'll see we'll see a little bit
of Poker in this uh in this chess
tournament you know I like that all
right well there you go play like a girl
go for the poker go go for the bluff
there's actually going to be a combined
poker and chess tournament in the aisle
of man in a month and nv's
playing right you mentioned that to me
should be pretty exciting um but Amir
scripko said he's not very well no that
he Bluffs too much he said NBL Bluffs
too much so FYI have to come out of
retirement for the poker chess
combination that sounds like fun over
there and we've actually got Taran
speaking of uh of Bluffs and high stakes
this tournament has got a lot of prize
money at stake true so she's going to
give us the scoop on the uh the money
off top all
right yes that's right Jen so not only
are these guys playing for their world
rankings but there's also quite a bit of
money at stake they're playing for a
total of
$35,000 the first place winner will take
home $ 100,000
but guess what sixth place last place
they get
$220,000 just for being here just for
showing up so not a bad Payday for these
guys they have a lot of money here on
the line all right we'll take it back
down to you
guys well these players are fantastic
players best in the world I think
they're excited about the money of
course best in the world is is
even better still I exactly those rating
points rating points are crucial and the
pride that comes with being known as
world's number one um sponsorship and
everything else Magnus Carlson world
number one gosh I think for close for to
four five years now he's he's been
cruising but he's in he's having trouble
both in the tournament and this game and
this is crucial for the tournament
standings with Bano at two 2 and and a
precursor perhaps to a a long-standing
rivalry um maybe in order to be number
one or number two in the world you have
to have a last name that starts with car
that is what we're gonna
see okay and we've got Maurice Ashley
actually for more I think on our our
Thriller of the day with a romantic
sacrifice B takes up7 Check Yes an
incredible move by Carlson but as you
said Jen maybe all Bluff he might have
seen the Contours of an interesting line
and options as well but there's one
predominant feature we should note and
it's the presence of Black's two Bishops
white no longer has any Bishops on the
board so he will not be able to compete
along those diagonals as black starts to
slice and dice into his position so you
take a look at one of these lines after
the move Rook to f8 check this is the
main line for us and King to H7 just a
quick note the computer is not talking
about this move at all but I just
glanced at what about this something
Carlson might have said maybe I can play
Rook takes King takes and get something
here is there a way to get at this king
that's in a little bit of trouble the
engines think no you're not going to get
particularly along the diagonal you
might want to play a move like Queen to
C2 for example but this bishop will
always be ready to defend the position
so no discoveries are going to really
work out in this line in fact black can
ignore this move and just play Queen G3
and go about his business saying I have
this position under complete control
well the other line is the main line
we've been looking at from here King H7
Knight takes on h8 Jen you asked the
question why not Bishop G4 in fact
Bishop G4 is playable too that's a
problem for Carlson black actually has
multiple defenses here black is not
feeling that much pressure once he CES
down and realizes this move Bishop G4 is
playable and if you play a move like
Queen F1 trade off and take a look at
this car move again the bishop saying
you're stuck in there and I'm the one
who's attacking Bishops controlling the
board this dark Square Bishop is a
monster this bishop keeping everything
under control on this side so in fact it
is white who is in trouble here looking
to find a way to prove that his
sacrifice that has won him material an
exchange and two pawns for a minor piece
May in fact be losing him the game if
he's not careful and you can see there
the normally cool and calm Magnus
Carlson is indeed looking quite worried
about the State of Affairs God
that's right thank you Mari some
thrilling variations here and the uh
online audience of course is thrilled as
well we've got one particularly high
rated player Grandmaster Nigel short
said that he could not hope one could
not hope for more thrilling games in the
singfield cup I totally agree um top 40
chess points out um that's a tweet we
have here on the screen or hashtags cup
if Fabiano Carana wins in the sink Cup
today his rating will be closer to
Magnus Carlson than anyone's been since
202 12 cuz of course that will bring
Fabiano up while bringing Carlson down
this head-to-head matchup we' got
another funny comment um it's evident
that the weak point of Carlson is the
calculation we call them keyboard
Warriors oh boy that is so wrong that's
wonderfully wrong but I just appreciate
it and fny by the way the um the
physical posture of Magnus uh normally
he he's got this kind of laidback Surfer
cool but uh a moment uh there ago when
we were really focusing in on him he
looked simply worried and he has by the
way played the move Rook f8 check and we
have seen King
H7 and did we see another move by the
way after King H7 did Magnus capture The
Rook already um don't think so yet no
we're still we still got Magnus on move
um Rook F check he spent 10 minutes on
that move uh Fabiano spending 4 minutes
on Queen G5 as you point out once he
started to see minimum Perpetual he can
save some of his calculation for later
or for while Magnus is thinking a good
practical decision absolutely and again
Queen G5 uh really me met the needs of
the position your queen is under attack
Suddenly It's Going On the offensive as
well as defending some key uh moves and
Maurice has got some lines to share for
another game I believe actually and we
did have a a request any chance of
seeing the other games only if they also
sacrifice Bishops yes and we're going to
get our wish because right now Nakamura
has the opportunity to get a decisive
Advantage with a sacrifice of a bishop
we just saw the move Knight to G5 by
topalov Knight to G5 threatening to
capture on H7 maybe get a maneuver in
the position he's also threatening to
take the Knight on H5 by the way so this
looks like an All-Star move but wait the
computer has discovered Bishop takes F2
check totally overturning the apple cart
this move now if you recapture King
takes F2 Queen to D4 check and it's
white who's being sliced look at this
monster Bishop you can't move to any
square with this king king to F1 just
drops Knight G3 and that's a sweet
looking Checkmate so that's a problem
Queen D4 check must be answered by Rook
to
E3 and now Rook takes on E5 ignoring
everything just going after after this
one piece we can throw in the move
Bishop takes H7 check but so what after
King to f8 now the main question is how
do you defend this Rook you can't move
your knight because your queen is going
to be taken that's one of the best lines
actually now because you're in Desperate
straights after Queen to E2 simply Rook
takes G5 and we can compare the Kings
this guy is the problem plus this pin is
happening this bishop might be trapped
this Knight is thinking of coming in the
game Queen to H5 Queen to H4 check all
kinds of moves after Bishop takes F2
check the computer saying that's it
white is busted well clearly it's not
that easy but for a guy like Nakamura
who's used to sacrificing I've seen him
sacrifice a queen on F2 and drag a king
into the into the position and then just
eviscerated I think right now he's
studying that move and we're going to
see Bishop takes F2 check once he comes
out of that deep calculation guys
amazing absolutely agreed we just saw he
Carl Nakamura looking at Carl game now
he's looking up at the sky he's going to
say I'm going to show you how to
sacrifice a piece on F2 right remarkable
echo in both games week F2 Square week
F7 Pawn right and one perhaps working
better than the other in this case
Bishop takes F2 as begging to be played
in fact I don't really see uh a not only
a better move but obviously in terms of
we have the situation with the queen on
H uh Queen on D1 is attacking the Knight
the bishop has this uh threat on H7 this
is an absolute must the problem is topof
has forced his opponent to sacrifice and
the problem is the sacrifice Works King
takes F2 and problem is it doesn't
matter check Rook E3 Rook ties all these
pieces are just yeah right and I'm
sitting there thinking well Bishop takes
H7 is not really the move that you want
to do I was thinking maybe a better
chance of holding on was this move
Knight E4 except there's a really sweet
uh winner you can just take on e4 right
no I was even thinking there's something
even better notice that the king and the
Rook are connected to one another if you
can push the king away and you can yes
this check and look at this sneaky
little Bishop oh That's All She Wrote
right there Bishop A6 and this was
Child's think that E4 was in defended
because your knight on D2 is pinned Oh
you mean just go ahead and grab it it's
probably not as move but after gra and
there's a double pin exact there's this
queen on D1 and the look at those Roy
Lopez pieces maybe you should start
playing The Bishop's opening because you
know you get your pieces developed more
quickly no one of the things about the
Royal LZ and that's what makes the
Marshall such a popular opening is that
white it is is kind of like uh backwards
for a little while his pieces are in the
back that's right so that's why
sometimes you see brilliant attacking
winds um for black and the Roy Lopez
yeah it's true it's true I mean when
white is uh too passive on the back rank
um with this Bishops I want so don't
castle and don't play Lopez those are
our lessons today no no no so this all
started by the way from B4 B3 attacking
the bishop the bishop dropped back bring
it to the back yeah Bishop dropped back
just to keep this Pawn on e4 uh well
protected Queen D7 E5 and all of this
happened Knight G5 that was a big ass uh
topof certainly overestimating his
position and Maurice are you trying to
say that there's yet another game that
it's exploding this can't be real
absolutely and on the F2 Square as well
take a look at this madness that's going
on right now the move Queen B6 a daring
move by by aonian he's just played Queen
to B6 the point being that this Bishop
he's claiming is pinned but actually
he's not pinned at all he's trying to
aggress this Pawn but it turns out that
mvl can just play the move D5 and say
forget about F2 if you want it you can
have it Queen takes F2 check leads
nowhere after the simple King to H1 and
now it is actually white who's
threatening to take on on G7 take on B7
sometimes even play a move like Rook to
F1 and Black's pieces aren't developed
yet and look at this bishop going
straight through to this Rook in the
corner it is white who is dominant here
if he finds the move D5 he's not
sacrificing on F2 I guess he is
sacrificing on F2 he's giving away his
F2 Pawn in order to open up the game and
just blast black off the board all he
has to do now is find the move D5 and
it's going to be all she wrote for
aronian his position is going to
collapse like a house of cards just
incredible all these games now extremely
exciting moments we're waiting for him
to play this move D5 and aonian will be
in deep trouble guys looks like reaching
for it wasn't he I mean he really was
Max is ready to play the move5 thefield
cup shirt good cool represent one thing
I love about the uh the swag they give
away here is it's actually really nice
it's not like that t-shirt you put in
the workout drawer it's like the one
that you actually wear under your
Blazers yeah they got good polos here um
what around and uh I thought going into
this round that it was actually again an
overused word but a critical IAL one as
the tournament's shaping up if vesselin
goes down 0 and three oh my gosh what I
thought it was going to be hard to up
stage round two yeah and I was
wrong yeah I'm with you on that one I'm
bad at predicting but that was wow so D5
I'm really expecting that uh that move
will be played just as I'm expecting
with a high degree of certainty that
Hikaru is going to play Bishop takes F2
check I mean he he wants to do it it's
and vesselin knows that he's overlooked
something in his calculations he
complained about it yesterday that he's
just not calculating well and this looks
to be another case this move Knight G5
was simply a blunder AIT
he overestimated his position um let me
ask you this who do you think is most
likely to uh grab a draw today we we
know that grab a
draw I don't know if anybody grabbing a
draw you think there's going to be three
decisive games today it sure shaping up
that way yeah of the three um I think I
think topalo is going to lose okay I can
see that Bishop F F2 looks to happen
yeah whereas Magnus better chances to
save relatively speaking yes but we've
still got to see how that I think Magnus
after making The Rook check by the way
has still gone into a a deep think he
hasn't uh uh concluded which is the best
capture Rook takes h8
check drawing Black's King into the out
of the corner but uh giving up material
or playing Knight takes h8 because the
variations that we've been looking at
with Knight takes HH these Bishop G4 and
queen E3 ideas uh I think Magnus
recognizes that uh Queen E3 check Bishop
G4 variations are actually in his
opponent's favor and I think he's
looking for a save here he would be very
happy to find a way out but who's better
at that than him right oh he's he's he's
the Houdini of Chess he's he's
remarkable take H off the board and then
start and then figure it out yeah but
okay that would be technically within
the rules of Chess but bad Sportsman
ch let's just see did no okay um max did
not play the move d4 D5 he's played by
the way a very human move uh I must say
with this Rook on F5 it's a very natural
thing that white wants to do is play E2
E4 but as Maurice was pointing out the
difference between playing D5
immediately in playing E4 is when you
play D5 immediately The Bishop's
diagonal remains open after for example
E4 you go drop back with the Rook D5 The
Bishop's not as effective because the E4
Pawn is simply in the way of The
Bishop's diagonal so I so E4 looks like
a very big missed
opportunity still looking pretty hot for
white though indeed I mean you wouldn't
want to be black year would you even
after
E4 I would I would be very happy after
E4 I wouldn't want to be black after
D5 and Maurice has got something he just
like his eyes just went buggy what
happened Maurice well it's incredible
because in both
games the opportunity has just slipped
from their hands Nakamura did not play
Bishop takes F2 check instead he played
the Comm G6 protecting his position and
Vash gra did not play D5 which was
winning which just the computers just
saying you're almost up a piece in the
line after D5 it's so it's so excited
about that position so missed
opportunity at the exact same moment
both players back down and missed these
crushing blows I'm sure they will be
kicking themselves when we show them
this you think we will I'm going to be
asking that question when I interview
them for sure but definitely a moment
lost however in nakamura's case he might
have given away something but in vashi
lra's case he still has a great position
E4 is a tremendous move and this move
still puts black uh under tremendous
pressure he will be probably donating in
exchange soon according to according to
the computer because his position is so
bad white is beginning to expand in the
game with a lead in development and the
whole nine two Bishops everything isn't
in favor in the meantime topalov has to
stare at this position which is not easy
at all for him still uh after this move
G6 but he has to be counting his lucky
stars that the position did not explode
after Bishop takes F2 actually the
computers are now saying that this
position is dead even so Nakamura missed
a gigantic chance to capture on
F2 he's gonna really hate himself a if
this game does not end in a win for him
guys remarkable situation that it
exactly the same moment uh two big
opportunities for decisive advantages
were
squandered literally at the same time
that's that's that's strange something
in the something in the air today uh
missed opportunities uh but but one of
the things that uh this move G7 G6
really attracts your eye you start to
think hey well I can just snabel a pawn
and in case of Knight takes H7 Queen
takes H5 check I'm a happy camper no no
no no no uh winning a pawn I think will
still allow these moves Bishop takes F2
and uh so forth and so on I'm thinking
that here um vesselin might start to
think okay pull in his horns a bit and
play a safe move like Knight
F3 opening up this bishop and offering a
trade of TR offering a trade of Queens
to neutralize the
situation if we've got oh sorry I was
going to say if vesselin is
very um optimistic and maybe his level
of confidence won't wouldn't justify it
uh even a move like Queen G4 uh the idea
behind Queen G4 is that in case of a
trade trade and the Knight comes to F4
then you're you're banking on this
discovered attack uh with Knight E4
Knight F6 ideas as well as Bishop takes
F4 that's right all right so meanwhile
uh Magnus has made the decision in his
game against kowana he played Knight
takes h8 he did so not work takes h8
check but rather takes h8 and in other
news uh Maxim vasher lra still with a a
lot of pressure on leavon aronia
um after PA but after E4 Rook f8 Bishop
to C3 very quiet approach I really Queen
yeah I was really thinking that this
move d4 D5 was simply begging to be
played I think what uh Max is counting
on is that with this move Queen B2 he
it's a double idea he wants to get a
battery going on the long diagonal as
well as a battery against his Pawn on B7
if he can induce the move B6 then I
think he's hoping that after D5 oh boy
trade a trade that's a big check by the
way you bring the king onto a light
Square so that this bishop can pop out
on H3 and Bishop E6 check would be
decisive this is what m ma is hoping uh
leavon will allow that's right I mean
this just looks fabulous indeed it does
so uh big pressure on leavon arone and
he still has to solve his problems
Maurice canny solve his problems he is
definitely in trouble in that position
white has all the trumps the two Bishops
the center the open files for his Rooks
Black's Knight sitting on the back row
that looks terrible right now but also
there's an important moment happening in
the Nakamura too game it seems as though
topalov has one chance right now because
Nakamura has so many Dynamic trumps with
his two Bishops as well I mean these
Bishops just look tremendous steaming
into the position this Knight getting
ready to hop to the F4 Square it looks
as though the smart defensive move if he
finds it is to toss in the move E6 and
the engines are actually now saying that
he's slightly worse after this sacrifice
but he needs to do it because he's going
to be a bit more worse if he doesn't so
after E6 Fe E6 and then the move Queen
G4 it is white whose pieces are starting
to grow a bit uh in power you see the
scope that his Pieces Just got because
of this move the best move given now to
keep some kind of edges Knight to F6 and
now the come Queen back to E2 now the
Knight can't jump to E4 and now he's
gotten control of the E4 Square his
Knights can go to that square and he can
play a bit more positionally down a pawn
but this Pawn he might win back and his
pieces are going to come alive once this
Knight lands on e4 so chance for him now
if he realizes it that he has can thank
his lucky stars the sacrifice didn't
happen on F2 and now he has a chance to
sacrifice and breathe a bit with his
defensive posture
guys wow uh quite a remarkable idea the
idea of E6 is very very sensible to
break up black uh kingside structure but
the idea of E6 combined with Queen G4
and then the retreat
that is a remarkably subtle
sophisticated idea that would not occur
to me uh when you go forward you want to
keep going forward I like the idea of E6
I like the idea of Queen G4 I like the
idea of Knight E4 as mauie say uh White
has to neutralize Black's initiative E6
makes a lot of sense let me just bring
that uh move that position up on my
screen I do like this move E6 I do like
the move Queen G4 and again as I proudly
say the move Queen E2 that retreating
move would not occur to me I would want
to linger over here on the king side a
bit I would be attracted to the move
Queen H4 how about you Jen wouldn't you
want to keep your king yeah this is well
you just you're you're you're you're
you're there you're there I mean and
there's a reason why you spend a lot of
Tempe uh to build up these types of
attack uh nothing decisive but there's a
potential blow on G6 there's also I do I
do want to point out that this Knight on
A5 uh could there be an exchange
sacrifice although it doesn't look like
too much opportunity here Maurice
mentioned that whites pieces could grow
as he brings them over he Maneuvers them
it's like that's what happens in Roy
Lopez lot you just maneuver your pieces
over to the kide and then you you drop
something you drop a bomb on the
position right that Bishop on B1 later
can come in after our sacrifice so um
meanwhile I'm really keeping a close eye
and seeing what Fabiano is going to do
in this game after Knight takes h8 we
looked at Bishop G4 Queen E3 check um
all possibilities that look sufficient
for black yeah I like the queen E3 check
Maurice youve got some more
throws just confirming what you said yes
an alternative is Queen H4 and the
engines are coming around to agreeing
with you Queen H4 four is a much more
aggressive move keeping the Queen close
to the king and the possibilities as you
mentioned are there for white to expand
but with a more aggressive Queen Once
that Knight leaves off of the D2 Square
it's going to join his colleague on the
king side and it is white who's looking
for the initiative in that position
still down upon pawn and still a smidgen
worse but definitely showing some signs
of compensation as compared to what he
was suffering a couple of moves ago
actually just one move ago uh this is a
great alternative guys what have so I
was surprised because um I thought
Nakamura looking up at the ceiling
suggested that he was looking at Bishop
F too Def and that he liked it something
about him seemed really confident to me
and I don't know I just I was that's why
I was surprised not as much as the
computer analysis more just his his
posture I would have bet the house on
Bishop F2 really I would have I mean i'
gone all in I mean that that uh hikaro
would have played that move and by the
way been broke yeah exactly I'd be out
of the tournament uh by the way topoff
did smack down E6 he has made the
sacrifice and even though he started
with two losses vesselin um he's a
player who loves the initiative he
Smackdown E6 I'm expecting him to play
Queen G4 bring it up on the board uh E6
and takes on E6 both have been played
right and this is where Maurice uh had
mentioned that the computer loves the
move Queen G4 just getting out of that
PIN and you know it's the USC tradition
of a student body right and just throw
everybody all bring all the pieces over
to the K ready to go Knight takes H7
right and Knight H7 is in the air and
we've seen this move Knight F6 well that
defends so just a just a point out
Knight H7 being a threat because if uh
if if King takes H7 there's that Queen
takes H5 check or queen G6 both good and
if Queen H7 Bishop G6 also Bishop
lurking on this B1 diagonal that's huge
so back to defend back to defend I'm I'm
glad that my sense of Chess
understanding hasn't uh um I haven't
lost much after analyzing I haven't lost
my my chess understanding under the
computer is warmed up to Queen H4 just
hanging around theu is happy that it
finally agrees with the Au oh yeah sure
I don't even like God why computer has
an awareness of yone much l agrees with
him but here uh I do like what uh
topolov is about to manage to do which
is launch a pretty Fierce attack I'm
really shocked that uh you know um
Hikaru who loves the initiative would
willingly subject himself when Bishop F2
was just begging to be played um by the
way let's just go back to our key game
that's determining uh the leaderboard um
and Fabiano is also uh looking at his
possibilities well he's got he's been
thinking for over nine minutes but he
does have another 45 minutes so um and
he recognizes this is crucial this is
pretty good time management I'd say in
this game right he's they're already on
move 20 I I think that considering the
stakes and the complexity of the
position he's been managed his time
quite well right so I'm looking at Queen
E3 check uh King H1 we're calling ox or
only move and then again uh the
computer's first move is Bishop G4 and
Maurice uh ages ago has pointed out a
long forcing variation but I mean the
human in me would go well I got to look
at Bishop takes H3 I mean this would I
mean it's just such a forcing variation
and I again we' have seen this specific
line ending in a Perpetual check right
but uh you would think if you were black
and you reach such a
position your instincts would say I've
got more than a Perpetual check I mean
I've got you know the king is is is
sitting there uh so so Queen G2 check
well I was thinking Queen check King
here and you're thinking to
yourself how can I get that Knight on C5
into the game how can I get that Bishop
on B6 You' got the bishop G3 check but
then he's going to run away so this is
where what you were saying you about to
say I was yeah so after after we that
King walks up I want to be able to play
Bishop F4 check so I'm looking at G5
here o exposing your king you might also
well Knight E6 gives up control of the
G5 uh D3 Square so okay G5 setting up
for the the very obvious Bishop F4 check
but now you're giving black an oh pardon
me white an opportunity to make a move
yeah to make a move and a very good
thing that white has that opportunity so
something like Knight F3 we're still
going for a walk by the way yeah that's
what I was hoping for but maybe the walk
will be a pleasant enough one for you
walking the plank right walking to into
s sudden death so Knight F3 might not be
the best uh I mean you could just play
you drop a lot of material here right so
you could play something like Rook f8
intending to sacrifice on F4 counter
sacrificing Rook remove some of your
attacking pieces and by the way you do
set up for a rook F7 check as ex
removing that so there's I don't feel
like there might not be enough wood wood
there yeah so we know we've got the the
the draw in hand so to speak the
Perpetual check um we play Bishop B6
setting up a discovery um after Queen G2
check okay Queen G have what Bishop B6
here well you have the possibility of
Knight C4 but then you can grab the i
the Queen exactly and uh reduce your
material deficit move well he'll go to
D2 unfortunately I mean oh oh okay
you're looking at that line indeed yeah
just giving back and by the way
unfortunately the the queen C2 check
could expose the black king a bit yeah
that could ruin some of so Bishop B6
Knight C4 but wow this is a lot to look
at for both players right yeah and again
from fabiana's point of view he came
into the game realistically speaking a
draw would be excellent for his
tournament Victory chances I'm pretty
sure he's analyzed Queen E3 to a
Perpetual check does he go back here and
he says okay now I want more now I want
Bishop G4 in the line Maurice pointed
out ages ago and I do believe by the way
that Bishop G4 does give uh black a
considerable Advantage because the line
Looks very forcing once again Queen
takes Rook takes again it's very hard
for the human to give up on this bishop
takes H3 sacrifice the Knight is trapped
it's got to come back then suddenly Rook
comes out here to F6 attacks the Knight
Pawn on G3 is hanging Pawn on e4 is
hanging Knight on D2 is hanging not much
of a better move than Knight F1 and
recovering some material with Queen
takes E4 and black black for choice just
this ending again we're just following
the mainline ending that Maurice had
pointed out to as ages ago that black
could get into a position of rook and
Bishop versus rook and Knight and um
have a have superiority for sure better
rook and better minor piece Magnus would
love to have Black's position
Grandmaster Yan gusta did from chess 24
mentioned that uh Anish giri first
pointed out that Carlson's love for
Bishop G5 in Spanish structures is
unhealthy an unhealthy love for Bishop
G5 um I love pins too so I'm guilty uh
count me I I I share the same weakness
as Magnus Carlson not the same strengths
unfortunately but the same weaknesses
and uh let's move over to Teran who has
a little behind the scenes look at how
this sinkfield cup coverage all comes
together all
right yes Jen I join you guys in the
bottom floor of the chess club of St
Louis if you follow me this is our
production setup right here we have our
directors and producers you can see all
of our monitors and even all the lit up
buttons that they push to make this show
go on air these are our Graphics guys
and then I'll take you into the studio
behind this door
here and we can come say Hello to Jen
and yaser right over hereo we've got our
camera crew and then we have Maurice
over here in your little corner how are
you enjoying it I'm loving it these
games are tremendous tremendous fights
it's all you could ask for when you're
doing a chess tournament you're
commentating you don't have to face any
other the pressure you just get to trash
talk about the games it's the best thing
in the world you know how to trash talk
too from Brooklyn you know we we know a
thing or two now some people have been
curious is you've been using this board
all during the broadcast how does it
work how do we know where the pieces are
during the broadcast well it's a
touchscreen so you're able to to move
anything you want and and right now it's
a critical situation uh kyana can either
take here he Queen takes G3 is the best
move sometimes this touchcreen doesn't
like my finger so I I have to go to the
mouse and and grab the piece like
so um I I think it's some oil or
something on my I think it was the
chicken wings and trying to get the the
the food off my finger but but uh it's a
great setup and you're able to analyze
and get all the screens going so it's a
lot of fun now I understand there's also
a magnet that we know where the pieces
are at all times for each player too
correct that's on the dgt boards that
the players are using so it's automatic
it just comes in it's great technology
for chess in this generation I mean
before we we had those demo boards where
they had to pick up the pieces and put
them in slots that was that's seems like
so many ages ago now now the take
technology makes chess presentation
fantastic awesome well thanks let me get
out of here these guys have a show to
do thank you tan that was uh that was
fantastic that was very unexpected I
know I felt shy I'm on camera all the
time but now it's like a camera on a
camera and I'm like uhoh oh boy that's
that's too that's too many levels for me
now I'm embarrassed right exactly now
suddenly we have to check to make sure
we're looking well but it's nice um by
the way I wanted to mention on one of
our breaks that the security is rather
LAX around here and uh we allowed Rex
singfield
our to come in and snabel on our food
and I was explaining to Rex
snab uh that it is um great to be a
commentator on uh chest tournament where
the games are so exciting it's very very
hard when the players are playing very
Ultra solid and Ultra safe here uh the
players are swinging for the fences and
it just makes our job so much easier and
I was basically thanking him that I can
be part of this historic event oh
absolutely the best not me the best
tournament ever maybe not just the
strongest my unbiased now here's a
thought and I was talking to Rex about
it and I think he's absolutely right on
all the great historical events you've
had tournament
books and uh he was encouraging um us to
start to think in those terms we should
get uh the players to annotate one of
their best games from the tournament we
get all of the um people here that have
been writing a copy about what's going
on during the event lots of
photos yeah and have a tournament book I
think best part about that is it'll give
something for you guys at home to buy
there you go oh the Cubo I mean you
you're watching us for free right right
oh you can also come out here and buy
tickets the Q Boutique apparently has an
online store now as well oh cool so if
you want to support the St Louis chess
club and all these amazing initiatives
they're doing there are ways for you to
involve your wallet and join the club
just join the club make uh the St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center your
favorite charity that's right thousand
members en counting so um we are going
to take a quick break before we get into
the thrilling action approaching time
pressure here at round three of the
singfield
cup
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm Magnus Carlson and you're watching
the sinkfield Cup live here from St
Louis how can you not watch after that
yeah um and we do have Grandmaster Marty
Ashley with the solution to the Magnus
puzzle the Magnus Carlson puzzle that we
presented for a break I'm sure you guys
all got it it's a tough one yeah well I
mean The Puzzle Master thinks we have a
very sophisticated audience and we do
because he's throwing out some really
interesting puzzles well this one is
definitely one of those slash and burn
puzzles so at least the first couple of
moves you I'm sure you analyze pretty
quickly the move Bishop takes Pawn was
the move and after Pawn takes just keep
going Rook takes Pawn with check forcing
the king to have to take you're not
going to allow The Rook to stay alive
here after Rook 87 you'll be mated so
Knight takes and now Queen takes and
wondering exactly how you defend the
mate on the H7 Square well there are a
couple of ways but neither one is really
appetizing black chose to move Knight to
F7 and white very commonly played Pawn
takes Knight so now although down a rook
that King that black king has no more
protection and is about to get creamed
by White's pieces so King to G7 was
tried and now the move Rook to D3 just
continuing the attack straight black in
deep trouble here tried Rook to D6 and
after Rook to G3 check Rook to G6 and
now Queen to E5 check and the Queen and
Rook are just circling that King now and
the game ended quickly after King takes
Queen check and then he tried to stay
connected to his King that was The Rook
only to to fall for Queen to D7 mate how
many moves was that uh it took from move
21 to move 29 I'm sure you guys analyze
8 n moves deep just at a clip like
Magnus back to you guys wow I love that
though that's like a little epet made in
the middle of the board right yeah it's
ni one but boy it's a it's a tough one
and like like Maurice was saying very
sophisticated audience needed to find
that strong players listening I mean so
far we've gotten shout outs
from
and Nigel and I'm sure Trent you had
mentioned exactly yeah and we do have
some moves in our key game Bishop G4 was
played okay so uh we have seen that uh
Fabiana car caruana ISU the Perpetual
check that was on offer he did go for
the variation suggested by the computer
Bishop G4 Magnus played Queen
F1 again again A variation that uh
Maurice had pointed out some while back
so the players have been playing slowly
um I think Maurice was looking at Rook
f8 Queen f8 and so forth instead we see
this move Knight D3 wow big time move
that's uh that's a big move here and oh
and that just that just appeared on the
board huh and the idea uh that Karana is
hoping for
is that in case uh White grabs that rook
in the corner there's no way that he can
withstand this brutal checkmating
attack uh of black right before you had
Queen G1 but now Knight F2 check seal
the deal big time take the queen take
the queen no take the king Take the king
exactly wow so Knight
D3 and uh Magnus Carlson under all kinds
of pressure here he's got to come up
with a a big time move himself how what
can he do so Queenie three cheack on on
and and and just to note that um Fabiano
spent almost a half hour on Bishop G4
But Then followed it up with Knight D3
instantly rather quickly so let's see
what he has in mind in case
uh uh Magnus captures the Knight with
Queen takes D3 then Rook takes f8 a lots
of pieces are are hanging there's this
E5 check so E5 check we can we can in
Bishop F5 right we take this um we also
could take we could also play Rook d8 um
and and score your oh oh that's a nice
one nice nice eye there Jen Rook d8 I
like that move very much as you say that
Knight on F7 isn't going anywhere Knight
pardon me the Knight on h8 is not going
anywhere for the moment and maybe uh
skewering that Rook on D2 uh the Knight
on D2 is better
although you are giving me the
opportunity no you're not Knight F7 is
met by the ssan zoo Queen C5 check and
the Queen on D3 uh White loses on the
spot in fact so he has to find a better
move than Knight F7 perhaps moving the
queen but this looks very nice now
everything working for black great
attacking pieces I mean you do you can
yeah and queen F5 check here does it
work because the Knight is hanging we
just hang uh we just we just capture the
queen and pick the Knight yeah and if we
try Knight F7 well guess what we could
get skewed in a different way by Queen
C5 check King H1 Rook F2 and oopsy da Z
there goes the night and magnus's
tournament uh takes a big dive and
caruana in the driver's seat here so
Queen takes D3 is not
uh it's not looking too hot not looking
hot at all oh my goodness uh Maurice uh
what has Magnus got to do to save his
position he looks
in to my
eyes he's in bad shape Maurice help me
out here what am I missing what an
incredible sequence by caruana believe
it or not the engines are saying that
black is only slightly better in this
position slightly
half a pawn better but you've got to be
in shock no matter how cool you are
James Bond cool is is Carlson but this
kind of move man this is like Dr No with
a gun to your head this looks really
really bad uh Knight to D3 just
sparkling scintillating Chess By by the
number two in the world the youngest
player in the tournament Fabiano Carana
he's got all these attacks every white
piece looks like it's hanging hanging
except for these hiding back here just
to stay away from Black's pieces it
looks as though the best line so far
that the engine came up with well now
it's been churning somewhat and it's
saying it has to go down this queen Jake
D3 path it wanted to try the idea the
weird idea Knight to G6 at first but now
it's realizing although that's defending
this Rook trying to somehow get this
queen to bail by taking the Knight it
now is starting to realize that this
attack is just way too powerful in the
long run Queen takes on G3 and now the
reason for Knight G6 believe it or not
not only to defend the Rook but to throw
this Pawn in the way so that this Knight
can protect it and just fight off that
crazy Bishop on the C7 Square however
black can be cold blooded right now and
play this line and leave his own pieces
hanging in this position here now this
is a highly dangerous position for white
he's got to deal with the fact that a
check could come this bishop could end
up on this long diagonal with a king
just staring there waiting for it so for
example the move Knight back runs into
just a series of moves Black's having
fun here just taking with Czech dropping
back going again with Czech obviously he
cannot be touched because of the pin and
then just dropping this bishop back how
cold blooded is that move just dropping
the bishop back knowing full well that
he can put his Bishop on B6 anytime he
wants white cannot touch his Knight with
the queen because of that move and the
position is just overwhelming we had
talked about this before kowana was in a
position where there was an
embarrassment of riches how do I attack
you your supposed sacrifice in F seven
has just completely brilliantly failed
and now it's just a question of how do I
put it to you he has found a tremendous
way and he's the one looking extremely
calm and confident while hunting down
the number one player in the world just
a tremendous situation for this young
man as he starts to rise and prove
himself on the world stage guys that's
right Maurice Fabiano Carana leaning
back here after some uh grueling
calculations no doubt um one thing that
also intrigues me here is that we've got
a little boy um in a green t-shirt he
looks like he was the one taking down
the chess moves but he's been there the
whole time it's been like three hours
look at that kid wow that that's a
dedicated fan well he's getting I mean
if he's going to pick a game to sit to
stand and watch for three hours he's
picking the right one exactly good eye
well again I just boldly point out the
obvious that the vi the the number of
decisive games between these two players
is a remarkable eight five wins for
world champion Magnus three for Fabiano
and uh just uh six draws and it looks
once more like we're about to see a
decisive game between these two
competitors who are the future of Chess
uh not only chess today but it looks
like Fabiano and inspiring kids not just
that kid with the green shirt right
right there but kids all over the world
that like chess is fun chess is wild
it's not about draws like even at the
highest level we can play this like
swashbuckling exciting stuff and uh
we've got across the board all of the
games by the way are are are full of
fight and themm and vigor and maybe this
one just tastes a cake um this Magnus
game is Just Awesome tweets Daniel
wrench over at chess.com um do you guys
agree that there's great chest so far in
the tourning um nah I don't so it's been
pretty dull hasn't it yet no no no no
that I mean I before the game before the
tournament uh Rex and I are talked and
he said look I'm expecting amazing games
and I said well you know Rex you know
temper that a bit you know these guys
they don't lose that often but what
we've seen uh the players have really uh
produce wonderfully and I mean just
kudos to to to them all and going
through the games by the way every game
is exciting but look what has happened
in the topoff match for just a moment
when we left it topoff sacrifice that
pawn seiz the initiative with E6
followed it up with Queen G4 and queen
H4 as I would have expected and then
this creeping move Knight D2 to F3
unleashing the power of these Bishops
that have been dormant uh towards
Black's King the Knight after Bishop D5
to defend the pawn on E6 the Knight took
up this great Central Outpost in the
middle of board Knight E5 hikaru's Queen
in full defensive mode now for
black because we were eyeing sacrifices
on G6 exactly so hikaro seizing the
defensive with this move Queen G7 Bishop
D2 sweet little Tempo against this
offside Knight over here and if we see
for example a move like Knight C4 we
can't see that pardon me that would hang
a pie piece if we see a move like the
Knight dropping back to C6 first of all
we could take that and take the pawn on
E6 so if the Knight drop back um well
let's say k Knight just what we want
let's say black went in for Rook A8
defending the Knight check this out Jen
the bishop takes up this fantastic
diagonal now you're going to KN you for
me yes you saw it before he even got a
chance I mean or you all kinds of
sacrifices
I see you know storm Crow storm clouds
over over hikaru's position and
meanwhile I think one player is is
totally busto um Grand Master Maurice
Ashley has more for leavon ronan's woes
against
NV yeah that one's ugly and over I mean
it's all over but the crying right now
this position is toast we saw here the
maneuver with Bishop to C3 and then
Queen to B2 B6 black trying to hold up
this side white wasn't even interested
in that side just yet he played the move
D5 looking to break open this side as
you mentioned in the linez and after the
move Bishop takes Queen takes King over
he could have played this move Bishop H3
wouldn't have led to as much as he got
which was the crushing E5 pawns don't
belong on your fourth rank when you see
two pawns standing side by side in total
control you know you're in trouble in
this moment and now this bishop
Unleashed and awake he tried A5 but then
Pawn takes and look at this protected
pass Pawn making this Knight look silly
on this Square the Knight tried to rle
wriggle out unfortunately here cames
Queen here came Queen B3 check and after
the king went in the corner give me yet
another pawn and everything is falling
apart on this side and we see the move
Queen takes Rook takes and Knight C7 a
blockade but Knights don't like to
blockade on the C7 Square too far back
in their position now Rook to B7 and
after Rook to C8 now Rook to A4 and this
this position is simply dominant for
white he's played Rook A6 has black and
he's waiting to see what comes next or
actually white did play a move the move
H4 and King G8 and it's just a question
of can white find the way in the
computer suggesting the move Rook to D4
with the idea of going down to D7 that
looks pretty powerful and also pretty
obvious so it looks as though aonian who
was just a half Point behind Carana is
going to stay on one and a half while
mvl surges and he's reaching now for the
piece and it looks like he's going to
play it that hand is just just cocked
you see the way it's looking it's going
to go to that square not much for him to
think about a bit surprised that he's
even hesitating here and he's reached
for it and he has played the move Rook
to D4 and this should be ending quite
soon guys so the French man with two
names looks like he's going to catch up
ab and get his uh even score back on yes
so really great uh great performance so
far with the white pieces indeed and I
think we can see great things from him
because you got to admit yesterday that
was a little bit of bad luck falling
right into a very much so for somebody
else yes it wasn't even made for him
exactly and great preparation by
Vladimir shalof along with fabul
fabul caruana I hate to bring up an
unpleasant memory but another example of
bad luck um csky AB preparation that he
had prepared for for his world
championship you fell into it and he won
a brilliant game without absolutely
absolutely it's just a bad bad day at
the office when that happens could been
somebody else exactly I not luck in
chess but I think in this idea of
preparation and just falling headlong
into something that easily could have
been another victim and then you would
have known about the game exactly I
would I would have avoided it but there
you go that's how it happens and um I
just wanted to point out why this move
Rook D4 by the way is such a bone
crunching move you're white um is ready
to double Rooks on the seven uh break
the blockade of the Knight on C7 and
after for example A4 Rook down A3 Rook
takes Rook takes Rook takes A2 just a
second you're one move away but I've got
Bishop D5 check and the worst part is
that the king is about you got the ssan
zoo to Chase the king far away
from this pass Pawn after Bishop A2 Rook
A2 C7 the players can shake hands and
aonian will go down to his first
defeat and that looks like a very
forcing variation that's right I mean
that's a really important endgame Motif
actually just finding variations where
you can get that pawn to C7 and it's
defended by a by a rook and you and you
get the discovered you get your Rook out
of the way and then you promote it
exactly in our key key matchup game uh
Magnus Leon looking lonely yes ah it's a
horrible feeling uh nursing a lost
position um Knight D3 uh Magnus didn't
see any choice he ended up capturing uh
the Knight on D3 which uh we had looked
at captures captures and then Jen you
found uh your Eagle Eye there a tactical
eye this uh nice little move Rook d 8
with this skew against this um pardon me
this Knight on D2 I I did want to
correct myself however against Knight F3
Queen C5 check I could block the check
like this and so um Magnus could still
struggle on so it's not a definitive
over over over uh type of situation yet
but there is this are you ready for this
one uh after Knight D3 let's say Rook
takes Knight
takes there is this funny kind of
dance that I I was chuckling about all
right just improving the position of
your king slightly well yeah well the
Knight on the Knight looks trapped it's
not I I wouldn't doubt that black is
winning this one the Knight looks very
uh strange on the circuit let's try that
again we could for example well no we
still haven't trapped the Knight yet we
still haven't trapped the Knight yet the
Knight can jump out so Magnus not dead
dead but looking in trouble looks like
we've got another move in that game
actually um Fabiano playing um Queen
takes G4 just simp so either Rook d8 or
King takes h8 instead just Queen takes
G4 we talk about the calm cool
collected uh nature of this young man
Fabiana Carana
and that's
a a nice move so KN KN on h8 still
trapped absolutely and in the meantime
we're also eyeballing this Pawn on
G3 and you just clip a pawn and continue
play um by the way the obvious Rook F1
would allow a standard type of Checkmate
which we see all the all the time when
you get this open H5 yummy so and we've
got um Maurice is talking to us about
the uh
leavon Maxim vashir lra and leavon
aronian has continued to come upon the
lines that you mentioned hasn't it right
gone straight down that that pathway and
uh we're going to be seeing handshakes
very very shortly in this game um
because there's just no way that Black's
A2 Pawn is going anywhere this move
Bishop D5 just puts the Kash in he
instead of taking on C7 he actually
played Bishop D5 check uh first I beg
you paron so after Rook takes C7 um I'm
sorry I think he already played Bishop
to D5 check so he didn't even wait for
A2 uh we just a second I I apologize so
Rook takes C7 Bishop D5 check
immediately rather than Rook C7 and then
yeah so just a slightly different move
order right but we get precise it's just
a transposition ESS transposition
exactly we get the same same variation
where the end and the handshake wow as
predicted wow another decisive result in
the singfield cup and MBL rebounding
after this difficult loss yesterday
meanwhile Lan Arona now on an even score
and I tell you this is uh a beautiful
game this will go down in his collection
of best games because he really really
outplayed leavon in this one I mean the
leavon very early made that decision to
go for the pawn and give white this
dominating Bishop on G2 very very
strange Jud Beau Bishop so Bishops are
good and don't wear orange that's what
we learned from this game wait a minute
orange is the color of Holland
[Music]
Holland you're upsetting our chess fans
don't say that no orange is great but no
seriously this was a very strange
judgmental decision by a judgment
decision by um leavon in this game
because this looks like a guy of game
that leavon would win with white he
loves sacrificing and having
un imbalanced imbalanced positions and
what about Maxim's repertoire his choice
of openings in these first two games
with wider couldn't be more different
yeah well it goes to show just how
versatile all of the players are at the
very highest they're they're able to
punch with the Southpaw or Orthodox only
play E4 in one game but in the other
game he actually started he started with
the game with Knight F3 and then with an
early G3 kind of uh much Tamer and the
other one just Mainline Scotch well a
shout out to Ben fold who came in very
early in this round and said Hey listen
we're seeing the stayed quiet openings
but they're going to explode into
fireworks and he he just nailed it
perfectly there's Ben right there Ben
fold over at lesters and Ben fold's not
shy about saying hey NBL is my favorite
player mhm who's alive he also El to
okay and it's funny because um I was
actually giving a lecture at the chess
club a few weeks ago and there was a kid
in the front row and he's wearing like
he little kid maybe about 10 or 11 he's
wearing sunglasses and I'm like what's
up with the sunglasses are are you uh
are you a big fan of Nakamura or
something referring to last year's soll
cop where he wore the sunglasses
successfully against Magnus Carlson and
the kidss like yeah I like Naka but I've
got an even more favorite player and I'm
like who like like MV out wow how cool
is that and of course he had watched uh
he had watched some of Ben fine gold
lectur um on the YouTube channel there's
lectures by all of the grand Masters who
give lectures here at the chess club and
there's one that I actually watched
before the singfield cup where Ben fingo
goes over some of his favorite NBL games
so I encourage you guys to check that
out and getting inspired like the young
boy you were exactly very nice well
after you're done watching these games
of course cuz I know you're going to be
looking for more chest after that now
speaking of little kids getting inspired
green shirt he's not leaving he's
staying to the
handshake and one of these one of these
kids is going to be his favorite player
um Carana and Carlson um do we have any
more moves here we do uh when we had
left it we saw this very cold blooded
Queen takes G4 just grabbing the pawn
Knight F3 and now uh there's a second
Pawn on offer as well as this Knight on
H
one day that Knight on h8 has got to be
captured so let's just imagine take it
eventually yeah let's just imagine King
takes h8 keeping this move Queen takes
G3 in the reserve in Reserve at the
moment uh Magnus is going to have to end
up playing a move like E5 to tame that
Bishop but I don't think it's going to
solve his problems magna's in big
trouble here and just on the on a
material note as soon as that G3 Pawn
Falls
the material will be even and uh Karana
has all the attacking chances that
without having sacrificed anything
that's right and a Time Advantage as
well what is the time just five minutes
more but still 18 minutes for 18 and a
half minutes and 13 and a half in
counting for Magnus Carlson who's now on
move and uh Maurice has some thoughts
for us on the other game that's
remaining um topalo and Nakamura and
absolutely Rich Game and maybe having
missed it once he might not miss it a
second time Nakamura a threat to the F2
Square it looks as though he has a move
that does not seem like it's possible at
first blush but may work out KN to C six
the natural Knight takes Knight looking
to put the bishop on the C3 Square can
be met by the
completely opaque Knight to H5 like
what's that about your rook's hanging on
this side it looks like I can take a lot
of things and you're only after this one
Pawn what's going on well it turns out
that if you were to play the move Knight
takes Rook then suddenly Bishop takes on
F2 back in back on track and now takes
takes King takes and now this move Queen
to D4 check and the King again is
getting mated Allah that variation he
had a long time ago and if Bishop to E3
to stop it then suddenly Queen takes on
B2 check and it's black who's winning
the game so a possibility here white can
control all this back here after this
exchange and Knight to H5 black could in
fact sorry white could in fact Play
Bishop to C3 and make sure that he's
able to get a queen back after it's all
done or in this position he could just
play for compensation which the computer
says is slightly worse for him but he's
been slightly worse for a while with
Bishop to C3 takes and takes but here
black will have solved the big problem
of this Knight on this square and could
start to push White's pieces back with
86 and now White's going backwards not
forwards so this is an option for
Nakamura if he sees it he doesn't want
to gravel by putting his Knight on B7
but it seems as though he could find if
he found this move and it seems as Am I
Wrong it looks that he has played Knight
C6 and Knight takes Knight is on the
board it's it's for Nakamura to come
back to the table to see if he finds
this crazy move Knight to H5 he could
play right now having sacrificed the
Knight leaving a rook hanging he's got a
real chance here wow that move Knight H5
is a big surprise move what a bizarre
move yeah but but visually it does make
a great deal of sense after all this
bishop on
F2 uh pardon me the bishop on B6 trains
its uh sights against the F2 pawn and
you do unleash the Rook at you know for
the moment you leave the Knight you
don't recapture the Knight but you you
develop this Counterattack against F2
Pawn
um tactically the the computers are
awesome they see these things the
players are you know looking a little
bit
more strategically well it would be
weird it would be kind of interesting if
he missed Bishop takes F2 or obviously
he saw it maybe missed something in the
variations but but plays but plays 985
which funny combination right right
stranger things have happened certainly
in this field Cup oh so far so good
absolutely meanwhile Fabiano camon
didn't take on h8 right away as you
recommended but instead played uh just
Queen takes G3 and now Magnus on move as
we bring in um a guest to our studio
Grandmaster lvan aronian number two in
the world he is with Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley Thanks Jen with grandmas leavon
aronian after a difficult loss uh leavon
what happened in the this game yeah I it
was a misjudgment I was very greedy I
have to say I thought that by taking
Pawn I I have a good play but I've
missed this whole idea of uh him
capturing with a queen on A2 I think I
had a good alternative around here uh
that I saw I was planning to play that
uh C5 here it's very interesting because
the plan is KN take C4 D Knight G5 and
Bishop
C8 so uh
so it's a it's an interesting position
but
then I kind of thought all right let's
go with the pawn and and here the touch
screen not working too oh sorry and here
I thought a take B and then uh Queen D7
and Knight comes to the A6 you know I
have a pawn but it surpris you with this
move Queen E3 yeah and I realized my
position is very difficult what I have
down of course was not very intelligent
Rook F5 and queen F6 I should have opted
for a position with a pawn down I should
have played Knight D7 here Knight D7 D5
Bishop takes B2 uh Queen B2 let me get
up to that yes and Knight
F6 of course black is Pawn down but
there are some chances to survive so
generally I think it was just uh uh
wrong judgment on on my side you said
you got greedy what was that about yeah
I thought you know it's a pawn after all
uh you know maybe
maybe I'll get the time to just
consolidate but I never got the chance
because I mean missing the idea that he
can actually allow me to take the the
pawn on A2 and my position is terrible
then yeah that that was critical for me
did you notice as soon as you played
Queen A3 and you started looking at the
position did you feel like uhoh I'm in
trouble now actually
not I thought you know I'll take another
pawn and only only after he took with a
queen on A2 then I thought yeah
something went really wrong so a
backwards queen move when the queen was
already aggressive was was in fact
surprising moment often missed by very
strong players one of those moves Grand
Master yeah it happen so probably black
cannot really uh play like this or if if
I play like this after Queen D2 uh move
number 10 I should consider playing uh
dc9 G5 and uh Bishop D5 yes I thought
this was interesting too with the idea4
H6 just try to you know try to hold on
here yeah I mean it's should be slightly
worse for black but at least although ah
probably I'm I'm not judging it right
well this is certainly uh a difficult
game for you you came off a victory
yesterday where you didn't play that
great but your opponent gave you a
chance not a chance today how are you
feeling about your form in this
tournament after three rounds uh so far
I'm not playing well that that I can say
honestly uh today I think uh I I don't
know I I just got too excited about uh
all this uh structure change but uh
I think I'll I'll try playing more solid
all we wish you the best of luck in the
best in the rest of your games Grand
Master Leon aronian after a difficult
loss now at 50% back to you guys thank
you Von and Maurice the the number of
decisive games in the SRO cup so far
we're we're being spoiled without
without question it's going to keep
going but um let's take a look at let's
jump to Magnus Carlson's game uh as we
uh wait for um Maxim vasher lra to talk
about his latest win thank you to
Grandmaster leavon aronian number two in
the world I'm gonna call him and Fabiano
number two in the world cuz it's kind of
like was number two in the
world kind of like for the event and a
live rating list so here we've got a
situation where Magnus looks all pinned
down um so we saw this position um King
takes h8 now E6 has has occurred to
defend that pawn on E5 but now what
about the Bishop switching to the other
diagonal Bishop B6 check your knight is
pinned so you're forced over to H1 and
gosh this looks dangerous I'm trying to
find a r you want to do the Rover
routine you want to bring your Rook to
uh F4 so that you can mate exact a
Checkmate down on the uh H file you know
that's what I'm looking for those RS
definitely well let's see well first of
all it's a darn good question frankly
Jen I mean this looks really tough uh I
thought that white might have to play
like Queen E2 instead of E6 or something
to get rid of the pin MH somehow well
I'm just wondering do you see a good
defensive move here the move Rook H4
just looks tremendous I have que6 Bishop
B6 chick has occurred and King H1 and
now the question is okay so you're
playing Queen
D6 I do have Rook F3 uh the point was
was that no I just take the queen I beg
your part KN
check I was looking at Queen takes
allowing Queen H2 but oops the White
Queen is just grabbed after uh this
situation oops so how am I going to
defend against Rook F4 I'm missing
something uh I'm
blind I'm well you just start with a I
guess you start with Knight H2 well the
queen on D3 is hanging oh yeah I mean we
have to I mean uh
so have we seen the move Rook F4 yet um
not yet no um Fabiano's still oh wait I
think we just see a move actually Queen
G4 instead of Rook F4 so clearly there
was a defense to Rook F4 of some sort
I I'm blind um oh okay um what what am I
missing I don't see the defense it just
looks
over a
E7 ah ah going E7 ah check and this is
the point the queen is in great shape to
play Queen H3 you take the pawn but
White's definitely defending this ah
thank you so that is why we have
actually seen uh the superior move by
Queen G4 so just trying to play the same
now instead of The Rook move just trying
to play uh Queen H5 here and give white
this horrible Knight on H2 where it's
really defensive can switch back to
playing Bishop C7 right and I think
Magnus is simply lost I just this looks
terrible for for uh the world champion
but we do have a special guest in we've
got a grandmas Maxim Vash who now is
back on an even score and winning a lot
of American chess fans it sounds like
indeed that's right and he's with
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley we are with
the number one player in France and one
of the top 10 players in the world maim
Vash lra first of all congratulations on
your game thank you very much now you
played this game and we saw this
sacrificial possibility with takes on B3
and then you played this move Queen to
E3 you had obviously seen this coming
what did you feel right at this moment
did you feel like full compensation no
way he's getting out of this
one well I thought maybe it was not so B
but in terms of political play it's
really difficult already I thought
actually Leon's best chance would have
been to just give back the pawn up I
mean allow me to play D5 and somehow he
exchanges all the pwn on the king queen
side probably ends up being a pant but
there are still some practical chances
actually instead of Queen E3 also
interesting was maybe Queen B4 yes the
computer did point this out and we saw
this as well this this was the preferred
move was Queen B4 actually but your
queen E3 was was good also yeah no
actually I didn't play Queen B4 because
I didn't consider that after Queen B6 I
have Queen C4 then I noticed okay maybe
okay let's go back the touch screen is
not working so I'm also using my left
hand because I'm on this side so it's a
little bit Yeah so Queen B4 Pawn takes
A2
actually and so that's why I didn't we
get too much but probably just doesn't
work for black so Queen B Queen
B6 Queen A8 Queen
B2 Queen
A7 and Rook F2
Rook F2 here
wow wow what a computer loves at Miss is
still winning what a move to spot coming
in advance Rook takes F2 well obviously
King takes F2 is not so attractive
because of Bishop takes look at that
geometrics to spot that move wow
beautiful and uh and the computer just
thinks but we can just take on A2 and
yeah everything's all right probably
just winning well still it's maybe just
winning that's on the 2800 level yeah
just just winning but but it's still a
bit messy I mean the line that the
computer gives so I don't regret too
much of course because Queen E3 also
seems very strong was very solid move
how did
it yesterday you lost a tough game and
now you had to clear your mind how it
clearly was either easy to do so or hard
to do so or you just you you know you're
professional you did what you had to do
well it's more or less I did what I had
to do so I mean I looked at what went
wrong
I not sure I spotted everything but then
I decided to forget about it I watched
some tennis this morning also and
yesterday evening so I mean pretty much
back to to a normal life after a loss
and try to prepare for the next game I
mean you cannot just allow an early loss
to spoil your tournament because then I
mean there still eight games against all
those great guys so you know I had I had
definitely to recover quite fast indeed
so the secret is look at your loss see
the reasons why and watch some tennis
exactly that'll do it well thank you so
much Maxim congratulations on your win
and best of luck in the rest of your
games thank you very much Grand Master
Maxim Vash grav after a powerful win
against the world number two for now
player leavon aronian guys back to you
and just want to point out that this is
the first Victory uh for Max against
leevon Aron and prior to this he had
lost three games so um that makes it a
little bit sweeter playing against a
player and winning against a player mean
to say that you've never defeated so so
mvl wow very very impressive game uh I
just wanted to say that that move Knight
H5 which was a crazy tactical move in
the game between topof and Hikaru
Nakamura was not played understandbly
not a big shocker not a big shocker I
mean the the computers are monsters in
tactical alertness and after Knight
takes C6 Bishop takes C6 what a human
what Naka wanted to do was trade off
this offside Knight for this dominating
Central Knight that didn't solve his
problems because after Bishop C3 setting
up this very unpleasant pin against uh
blacks uh Queen Naka Mora is giving back
the pawn with the move E5 vesselin topel
off to play looks like 10 minutes to 12
minutes so the players are pretty even
in terms of the clock but I think uh
vesselin has a very powerful initiative
here and and uh hikaro uh is under
pressure wow so we're going to keep our
eyes peeled on this while we watch
Magnus Carlson suffering um getting some
uh tweets about this game as well people
think that Carlson might be going down
we've got uh Claudia Muno our Scholastic
champ Champion here National girls
Champion she says she'll come out and
say it that she's really really sorry
but she's rooting for
Fabiana okay you don't have to
apologize chess fans root for whoever
you want
makes sense for some of the American
girls to be rooting for him right
exactly and it is nice to have our to
bring our International audience for all
these players who have fans from all
over the world we we see some Norwegians
chiming in about the TV program on on
Norway TV right about magnets oh
absolutely and I you just got to say the
Armenian Community as well leavon is a
national hero in Armenia and the
Armenian Community wherever he goes in
the United States turns out to I I've
seen them they just want to touch him to
have photos and his signature he's a
really big deal in Armenia and then
we've got Grandmaster Nigel short um who
said that one could not hope for more
thrilling games hash s cop what a
tournament and then a Bravo Maxim
just well done I think U easy for you
somebody's saying Maxim is awesome yes
he is and we've got Grandma's Maurice
Ashley with some news from our topalo
game well with my college French which
is not the best he I think he said I'm
proud to be French so uh yeah right now
I'm sure there are a lot of Frenchmen
and women who are proud to see their
player their top player take down the
number two player in the world well the
other game there was the chance to take
on F2 the first time for Nakamura and
there was a second chance to take on F2
he did not do either either one and he
is now worse for sure he has played this
move E5 which does not leave a great
impression at all because his pawns that
were the bones of his position have
simply disappeared from the board and he
has now uh lost the pawn on E5 Rook
takes E5 boldly is toal off playing the
moment he moves this bishop away from B1
all his pieces will be coordinated but
most critically we should note that
there's the possibility of this queen
landing on the C4 square with to that
King that move is going to be very
dangerous at some point for black their
sacrifices abounding for white so
topalov according to the engines now is
up huge a pawn and then some now
remember the material is equal right now
so when a when an engine says that
you're one point something up one means
a pawn it it's saying I you have a pawn
in your hand but he doesn't have a pawn
in his hand which is then saying all of
the pieces must be great and a pawn is
coming soon soon and then some the
initiative continues and all you have to
do is look at the pieces this bishop
here is fantastic these pieces are
posted on great squares the only
remaining piece to come is this bishop
which could go here and possibly to that
square this Rook is ready to jump into
the game Black's pieces look like
targets and most importantly this King
just take a look at that guy he is
worried about the dark squared bishop
and the light squared Bishop black is in
deep trouble right now Nakamura has
blown this game and he's going to have
to fight for his life in hope for
mistakes from topalov who's looking for
his first win of this tournament guys
thank you yeah that game is a firy as
well and meanwhile speaking of fighting
for their lives Magnus Carlson with uh
just three minutes less than three
minutes rather of course there is a 30
second increment but less than three
minutes for 13 moves he's just played
Queen to D6 um hitting the Rook on f8
multi-purpose move also um doing some
defensive Duty on H2 in case of Rook F3
and queen H5 type stuff not not to
mention the fact that f8 is hanging with
Jack right so question what's going on
with our our little Rover now well that
is one question for sure the idea of
bringing this Rook over to H5 I was
looking at the more for three uh just to
see if there wasn't
something uh going on in a variation
like this sacrificing oops sorry
sacrificing the exchange for two
connected pass pawns you're going to get
two pawns you're second p with this but
probably with the exchange uh Magnus
will figure out a way of holding that